[Musique]
je suis danseur artiste chorégraphe et
moi ma passion à moi c'est le hip hop
j'irai plus en général même la culture
urbaine
ça vous parle dans la culture urbaine
il y a cinq phases majeures ce qu'on
appelle le chant le rap le slam on à la
danse le break
le loc le debout le popping style nous
avons le graphe l'art visuel
le street art maintenant qui se
développe de plus en plus nous avons
aussi deejaying
excusez moi et le beat box d'accord j'ai
découvert cette culture à l'âge de 10
ans en école de cirque
je regardais des vidéos et là je suis
tombé sur une vidéo voit un type lesieu
qui tourne sur la tête à l'âge de 10 ans
j'ai 10 ans fut la maman maman c'est ça
que je veux faire je crois bien que
c'est vraiment 5 je vais faire elle me
dit quoi
vas-y mon fils fait ce que tu aimes
alors je me suis entraîné j'ai essayé
j'ai appris j'ai chuté
au final je suis là ce que j'essaye de
fait de faire c'est transmettre ce
savoir vraiment pour moi c'est une
passion c'est devenu une raison une
raison d'exister
au début d'année j'étais dans un bureau
en réunion à l'opéra j'étais avec le
directeur de l'opéra il me bat stanislas
là il ya de la place pour un événement
est ce que tu verrais pas quelque chose
justice un battle de breakdance dans un
opéra vous en avez déjà vu un vous faire
encore mieux un battle de breakdance
inter générationnelle dans ce lieu
chargé d'histoire alors j'ai pris des p
tit tout petit des plus grands des
débutants et des professionnels
j'ai pris tous vous tous ces ingrédients
j'ai tout mélanger est ce que vous
imaginez cette sauce oui ou non
c'était magnifique alors c'était un
dimanche à rennes et je vous amusez vous
bien un public plutôt familial
d'accord ils étaient tous là en famille
et je l'aurais dit une phrase je m'en
souviendrai à mon avis toute ma vie
aujourd'hui vous êtes venu voir un
spectacle vivant en famille et bien
sachez que moi je suis venu avec une
partie de ma famille parce que quand on
commence quelque chose qu'on vit dans
une culture qu'on rencontre des gens
ddgn des grands qui pour moi m'ont
éduqué ont fait la personne que je suis
à l'heure actuelle et c'est grâce avec
je suis là je les remercie et bien
sachez que c'est un véritable bonheur
est aujourd'hui pour vous tedx rennes je
vous ai ramené une partie de ma famille
alors
veuillez applaudir comme il se doit à
pauline eliès est notre invité mystère
pas pigé la sava papilles alors pour
vous je vais vous montrer les bases du
breakdance ça veut dire les pas de
préparation cdpa qu'on fait debout
d'accord alors on y va ensemble jambe
droite en avant je croise une je reviens
à ma position
2 je vais chercher de l'autre côté 3 je
reviens chat vous comprenez c'est pas si
compliqué on va le faire un petit peu
plus vite
5 6 7 8
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
ensuite deuxième mouvement derrière une
deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit sur
le côté maintenant une deux trois quatre
cinq six sept huit ça nous fait donc une
petite chorégraphie
maintenant on va essayer de le faire un
petit peu plus vite 5 6 7 8
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
derrière une deux trois quatre cinq six
sept huit côté une deux trois quatre
cinq six sept huit
est-ce que vous en voulez plus on va
essayer de le faire en musique
d'accord ça marche
[Musique]
mieux
[Applaudissements]
ce
mais
[Musique]
non
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez en face de vous la relève
rennaise fait du bout et pour eux j'ai
une phrase pour vous et j'aimerais bien
que tout le monde joue le jeu quand je
dis hip hop vous dites transmission hip
hop hip hop ypres deuxième petit jeu est
ce que vous aimez danser que des gens
ont envie à apprendre
maintenant tout de suite on est posé on
a aussi on est bien allez venez tout
seul qui veulent monter venez à des
volontaires des volontaires
j'adore
[Applaudissements]
alors là du coup on va pouvoir se placer
au milieu où là il y en a beaucoup c'est
cool
au final une nouvelle équipe
allez venez c'est gratuit
alors maintenant le but du jeu ça est à
vous de danser tedx sur vous vous êtes
prêts c'est parti alors première jambe à
droite comme on a compris ça je reviens
2 l'autre côté 3 4 5 6 7 8 derrière une
deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit sur
le côté une deux trois quatre cinq six
sept huit on va le faire en musique non
[Musique]
doucement rockeur 3 4 5 6 7 8 derrière 3
4 5
une côte et 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 encore plus
vite
à suivre on y va je sais ce que tu as
maintenant ça qu'ici c'est très très
bien encore une fois 5 6 7 8
[Musique]
merci
alors on va enchaîner sur un petit
cercle d'accord maintenant je vais vous
demander c'est des passages individuels
la choque ça ça va en calmer plus d'un
c'est qu'ils ont envie exprimez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]